and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
begin with an obvious fact Joe Biden
your president is the worst president in
modern American history and at the ripe
age of 80 he's also the oldest sitting
president in American history now
needless to say he is not exactly aging
gracefully we all know Joe is a
cognitive wreck and it's now obvious to
everyone even the Democrats have to
acknowledge it the mob and the media
slowly are acknowledging it in fact many
top Democrats are now measuring the
drapes at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue the
White House waiting in the wings as
Biden circles the drain but no one is
more obvious about his presidential
Ambitions than the one and only
California governor Gavin Newsom now for
years Newsom has been auditioning to be
president he even took out ads you might
recall in Florida touting his great
leadership and what he laughably called
the true Freedom State of California all
right the reality is very different
California is by far the least free
state in the entire country without a
doubt it is one of the most expensive
one of the most difficult places on
Earth to start a business build a house
fill up your gas tank mow your lawn
power your home feed your family and
protect yourself it is the only state in
America that banned the future sale of
gas powered cars the only state in the
country that ban gas powered Law lawn
equipment the only state in America that
banned plastic packaging the state with
the worst coveted restrictions and
lockdowns including vaccine mandates
Mass mandates lengthy school closures
the state with the toughest gun control
regulations and I can keep going Newsom
just called the Second Amendment a
suicide pact while apparently surrounded
by armed guards of course we'll have
more on that coming up now naturally
California is also the highest tax state
in the country and yet this year Newsom
somehow faces a 24 billion dollar budget
deficit this is just one year after
Biden's Blue State bailout gifted
California with a whopping 100 billion
dollar budget surplus Newsom spent it
all every penny and then some in less
than a year by the way and now he's
looking for cash in fact it passed a
proposed wealth tax will find
Californians for simply moving out of
the state he wants them to pay a state
income tax when they don't live in the
state something that happens with a
great frequency of late now under
Newsome California is hemorrhaging
people now for the first time in its
history the state's population is
shrinking in fact California has the
highest demand for outbound U-Haul
trucks Texas Florida the Carolinas
Tennessee they're all seeing an
explosion in growth California has now
become unlivable for millions of
Americans but not because of its
geography or climate people are fleeing
the state because the high taxes
burdensome regulation the High Cost of
Living the scourge of homelessness and
violence and drug addiction addiction to
policies all of these problems all of
them caused and perpetuated by democrats
that have ruled the state now for
decades but now Gavin Newsom thinks that
he deserves a promotion he wants to
bring all of those special California
freedoms to the rest of the country now
Gavin Newsom is a con man he's a liar he
doesn't know how to manage a budget he
doesn't know how to fix the state's
housing crisis he doesn't know how to
lower business and development into the
state and obviously he has no idea what
the word Freedom really means hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else